what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we're gonna watch
one division today episode six before we
go into that first things first happy
birthday
to my fiance olivia it is midnight at
the time we're filming this
we just sang her happy birthday and then
i said now get the hell out of my face
we gotta film one division now
give it down out there all right thank
you so much to everyone who's been
watching our reactions so far the show's
been a total blast if you can go ahead
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction is up that would be
great also go ahead and hit that like
button it helps out the video a lot you
gotta mention of course that this is
reaction highlights full-length reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code are all over at our patreon
page we're over there at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs for many
shows like supernatural doctor who
attack
on titan jojo's bizarre adventure psych
avatar the last airbender a whole bunch
of other tv shows
as well and thank you thank you so much
to everyone who has shown their support
by becoming a patronage
and lastly eric over at nerd chronic
thank you so much for all the late
nights and early mornings where you're
hustling to make sure this ain't get up
at a reasonable hour up on the channel
you rock buddy i love you
let's get into
[Music]
vibration now this playing father while
you're editing this
i hope that you keep as much of the
recap
in the reaction highlights as possible
that should be most of the fact that we
should keep up most of the 10 minutes
that we're allowed to use
all right people need all that context
what the footage
she recast it's actually pretty
fully crazy they're like we know what we
did
was joking about keeping the recap down
there and i'm like
like damn it maybe there's something to
the recap there
i was here for this decade oh wow
wow that was strange
[Music]
pietro maximoff as himself directed by
jonah hill
halloween's a magical holiday
to be someone else for a day and scaring
people but mostly candy
she's like malcolm in the middle what
does that make me
hmm this is totally malcolm in the
middle the butterfly song
scarlet witch oh look at that
and a vision costume oh thinking for
mexican
wrestlers actually called carnegie
what do you mean you're all dressed and
ready to go i'm on to cover
but no that's not what you're supposed
to do oh
[Music]
i got the old xy chromosome uncle peter
i smell crime
i i can't get over the fact that evan
peters is here
he hurt you
wow
oh it's great oh they had fun
making all this oh don't use the last
five years as an excuse to be a
maybe coward a good thing you weren't
here when your mother died
because clearly you don't have the
stomach for this job oh you dick
oh oh that's poor
you dick no you did not go to captain
america's group
meetings you sure as hell didn't see
those
informational movies in school let's go
everybody in
oh
i like how the military side feels like
a 90s action movie now
it's not a competition tommy it is if
you're a winner
demon spawn every little one
eggs
is there something i can do for you
wonder
want something changed no no no no
don't do don't ask
i love the music this feels like a real
show i know
another glitch
[Music]
get out cry yeah
yo magic
[Music]
the snack for survivors
oh god that may have been the most
jarring one here
the incredibles and the parent trap
those didn't come out at the same time
what happened to your accent what
happened to yours
[Laughter]
[Music]
ellis avenue ellis island x-men mark
ellis
what the hell is going on
whatever's doing this must just be
really weak out here
are you waiting for something
i bet she's in special cameo
that was kevin feige
[Laughter]
what are you doing
it's here right you're one of the
avengers
you're fishing huh what's an avenger
what oh he doesn't remember anything man
nothing before i dead
why would you think that i guess you are
um
it's an awfully witchy laugh
okey-dokey neighbor
so i'm beginning to think sh all her
stuff is just a
nod just like one of the witch
to a character we're not actually gonna
introduce
she looks seriously traumatized there
yeah my way back into the hex will be
here in an hour
just gotta meet my guy over the ridge
let's roll it's a guy
it's a guy it's not the little screen
krieger squirrel girl back
the energy inside has rewritten your
cells on a molecular level twice
it's changing you're going to be a
superhero
have you seen your x-rays last week
i think mom and dad would have loved it
are you hiding all these kids up till
now what no need to traumatize me on the
occasional holiday episode
i didn't handle the ethical
considerations of this scenario as best
you could
i'm impressed seriously it's a pretty
big leap from giving people nightmares
and shooting red wiggly woos out your
hands
i've officially hit really confused
level now
i guess we can really find out if he's
dead or not yeah
good so far
[Music]
oh no
no get back in there vision
oh shake it out you're dead
he's in trouble
no vision get back in sight
no oh
where's your dad hey don't sweat it sis
it's not like your dead husband can die
twice
they think he's dying
[Music]
jimmy do you see that something's
happening it's moving
oh she's making it bigger oh
she's making it bigger she's sucking him
back in
uncuffed uncuffed oh
is she gonna take sword with her
[Music]
oh thank god he's alright wow oh [ __ ]
oh wow
oh my god oh and they're clowns
too i love it
oh my god this is too much
[Music]
dude dude this is like
twister right now oh
wow
i am exhausted she just took over so
much in that moment
okay wow they have just really entered
raising the bar in questions
yeah and yet still confronting like
every question from last time
practically in some way shape or form
oh boy they're really good at not
wasting time all right where to start
where to start okay with quicksilver yes
let's start with the fun one here at one
point she looked at him and it was a
re-animated it was a corpse the way how
it was with vision he was talking about
how the details are all fuzzy because he
has a line in there
where he is telling wanda last thing i
remember i was shot
like a chump in the street or something
like that for no reason at all which
there was a reason you were fighting
ultron and the army of ultron robots
and he said next thing i know i hear you
calling me and here i am
okay did she
pull aaron taylor johnson's body over
here
somehow took the soul or something from
the x-men world and
slapped him here yeah she like seems
like she combined
like did a like a combination of them
and then i feel like there's like
obvious hints with that even talking
about you know
that line of kick ass it could just be a
fun little easter egg line because both
aaron taylor johnson and evan peters
weren't
kick-ass and they both played versions
of quicksilver so like oh maybe that's
what it is but once you saw the animated
corpse i'm like oh wait that kind of
changes things
yeah it acknowledges this version of
events for quicksilver and the aaron
taylor johnson version
experience that was first yeah yeah
because i mean like he's drawing from
memories
that are clearly ones that were shared
with
the aaron taylor johnson version of yeah
because they even have the line about
like what happened to your accent what
happened to yours
and he's saying the details are all
fuzzy yeah like oh [ __ ] so
and he's also got the memories of being
exactly there must be this like
slammed combination thing happening here
because there is that line that uh he
has too about saying like i think mom
and dad would have loved it but in the
x-men universe one
it's very much established that magneto
is the father of this version of
quicksilver but yet he's drawing on the
memories of the one from aaron taylor
johns
it's just all uh yeah i mean the details
are fuzzy
they really are maybe magneto is gonna
show up and reveal that he had something
to do with
the whole thing that'll explain how
these universes are like
melding together throughout this episode
quicksilver seems very aware
that things are different he's back he's
like meta aware of his role in causing
friction for wanda he's even has like
audience lines
like you suppressed a lot of trauma yeah
it's like
every line unleashed hello demon spawn
yeah exactly
you're testing because everyone even
says you're testing me i'm like is that
just a funny line
or does he intend to be here because it
seems like he doesn't
i do love the highly super accurate
costume though that they got it that's
very accurate uh right up to the hair
right up to the hair
the one from age of ultron is is closer
to the comics than it was for the one in
the x-men movies this is like pure
accuracy
and i mean all obviously with scarlet
witch and vision and i love like the
malcolm in the middle riffs there's
three brothers then the oldest brother
there's four
total his personality of the uncle is
like the the combination of
the the oldest brothers yeah both reese
and
the other one yeah whoever that one is
yeah there's times where it seems like
he's just super aware
of everything that's going on like he's
clearly aware that this reality isn't
real you know he even has a like age of
ultron reference line of
you know you're it's better than giving
people nightmares in the wiggly wool
yeah he seems aware of all this yet
there's a lot that he doesn't understand
himself
yeah or unless it's just an act i'm not
sure
any little line about hell or something
yeah i mean it certainly seems like he's
got i almost felt like that was his
brotherly role too is like
maybe he just knows her so well that
he's like oh yeah i can see exactly what
you're doing i'm just you know i guess
i'm okay with it it seems like for sure
we're building up to mutants we knew
that
somehow it seems like this series
specifically though
is finding its way to mutants there's
that line even where he says like i got
the xy chromosome and even though that's
not the same thing i was like that even
seems like a direct like
hint obviously you know like with monica
rambo
they're building up to her becoming a
superhero photon or spectrum right here
they're saying that by her
entering this wanda energy field thing
that she's created over westview
that it's rewritten her cells on a on a
molecular level they're building her up
but what does that mean everyone's cells
in the west view are having their
biology rewritten to
it would seem that anyone who comes in
contact with it that beekeeper is going
to have
power all the mutants from all the
mutants are going to stem from west
virginia yeah
that's right so they all come from a
pocket right here man that hayward guy
is a total idiot he just kind of gets on
my nerves like
the calls that he makes i mean he
obviously has a bigger agenda than
what's been letting on right
big surprise there he has a bigger
agenda he's
been tracking visions specifically there
was a
very interesting delivery when he sees
vision's body coming out like he wants
he's like really when he really really
wants to escape
it's like a combination of excitement or
something
like yeah like i'm testing him or
something right like
some kind of investment beyond just like
i want to get my weapon back
yeah yeah exactly you seem to at least
be like oh dang okay this kind of
confirms
my thoughts on my theory and i'm like
are they intentionally provoking wanda
is he intentionally doing this i
appreciate the approach of what they're
doing to kind of flesh him out a little
bit more
of that five year gap of oh man it was
there's a lot of trauma it was really
difficult grieving time because this
whole
series seems to deal so much with grief
he's talking about during that five-year
absence there was
a lot of grief and then you know uh he
has a line about advocating on behalf of
super-powered individuals
clearly not for that you know and
monica's doing way too much of that
yeah and then she even hinted towards uh
monica
having extended history beyond what we
saw in captain marvel at least this is
the way his
delivery line sounded bottom line though
he doesn't like supers i'm not sure
what it is that they're like some weapon
to take on superheroes i'm not sure what
the hell he's
his overall plan is but that ending
moment where
wanda does extend the
energy field out and just just
absorbing everyone i love the visual
action of it especially when the
the car is trying to get away to just
take the rear end of it
but it's like damn wander you're doing
overkill she's like you guys are gonna
keep
you guys gonna keep [ __ ] with me fine
i'm gonna take you all with me yes
zoom out i'm gonna take all of you
because it's like i just have to extend
it a little bit to grab vision
yeah and then she just keeps going and
now everyone's in there not everyone
but a lot of people are there monica and
jimmy they escaped but even darcy got
sucked in whoever this aerospace
engineer guy is who's gonna show up it's
gonna be like what the hell is going on
yeah this is your whole team then maybe
the opening the next one will just be
him just driving and
it'll be a solo character episode all
about this yeah
at this point i'll be down for whatever
they throw at us and then they can just
cut to 2000's wanda envision whenever
they feel like it but it's like the
glitches seem to be happening
more especially when vision's going
through that town and everyone is just
frozen it seems like the more people
that are out and the further you get
away from wanda the more glitchy
everything gets
but at the same time hayward seemed very
much aware of it for some reason another
thing he kept under
wraps because even wanda is having a lot
of i don't really know how i got to this
point either i don't really know how i
got here so
like is this a hayward guy is he
responsible for this and
in some way did he seem a nip did he
manipulate wanda in some fashion because
a lot of us were going to the theory of
agnes is probably agatha harkness i'm at
the point where i'm like it's probably
all nods there's probably no mephisto in
here
i i don't think so as much as all of us
have been championing for them they have
these little lines all the time that
kind of make you think that it's going
that path but that scene with agnes and
vision especially she seemed very much
traumatized like she's trying to escape
when she's awoken she's
having like a mental breakdown you know
just kept shouting the word
dead dead and she said are you here are
you here to help
us i feel like she's desperate and wants
out of there i don't think she's the the
witch
the ag at the heart i feel like it's all
just misdirect nods and stuff
yeah it seemed just too authentic the
way she played that i don't know for it
to be the sort of thing where it's like
he woke me up and then i
did a ruse on him you know and clearly
she was under some type of manipulation
guys as well because vision had to
awaken her
yeah so it's like in that split second
you wouldn't be able to go like my
agenda
you know yeah it seemed like she was
really caught up in the actual situation
and at the end you know it's like she
goes hysterical
and i feel like even that could be a nod
it's like it's a very witchy cackle that
she devolves into but even then i feel
like i feel like she was just losing her
trauma yeah terrific experience um
and the vision is uh he's definitely
dead
because the second he gets out of west
view oh i don't want to see pietro even
try to leave west view because that's
going to be even more gross and like the
way they captured that was so
just chilling i'm like wondering maybe
they sent in aaron taylor johnson's body
for her sword is clearly monitoring the
situation a lot heavier there's so much
of this that relates to wanda's
subconscious so i i don't know maybe she
rewrote his face so that it would be a
little less traumatic than looking upon
her
actual brother you know for the
fantasy's sake or something
i'm not sure because i'm like how could
she just summon his bo
if that is aaron taylor johnson's body
maybe it's like
wonder woman it's a different guy's body
yeah
yeah he did and he didn't revert to
aaron taylor johnson's face in that
moment or anything so it's you know
the x-men version of quicksilver but in
that predicament
yes so they are committed to this
transcription right now but also in the
recap that showed aaron taylor johnson's
i don't know what to make of that at all
and then also like with tommy and billy
with wiccan and speed okay their powers
have officially come into play
wiccans magic abilities and his like
very
strong connection with his father which
i find
very fascinating the way the show
presented it was i wanda kind of just
conjured up these kids
yeah exactly they didn't seem like they
were derived directly from
vision two yes but it's definitely
vision seed
yeah exactly there's a blood connection
exactly that's kind of an another
implication that these kids are
probably very real you know like i love
the uncle connection that quicksilver
had with them
it seemed like so much attention was
given to speed
in this episode because of his bond that
he was having and the fact that he was
developing those powers and the mischief
he's really resembling quicksilver in a
lot of ways
this version of quicksilver but that
whole moment with wiccan
seems like they made the fun and games
out of speed and then they really
brought wiccan and then because part way
through i was thinking like are they
gonna develop wiccans powers in the next
episode or something like that and i
imagine they will bring them to even
bigger because it seems like speed is
like fully formed now at least
because it wando she didn't even have an
inkling about vision being in trouble
yeah yeah yeah the other thing is you
would think she would have some way of
of of keeping that in mind
but the link was all through wiccan
being like i hear daddy
maybe she's fracturing herself to create
these kids and maybe that is absorbing
her ability to see
all oh and it seemed like it was hurting
him too
yeah i mean it seemed like it was it was
difficult to channel and yeah probably
he's probably feeling some of that
trauma that
vision's feeling at the moment yeah i
wonder what's going to become of them
hope damn
they're gonna they're gonna be like 15
nexus
and also you know the way how she hit
quicksilver away like she want she's
wanted petro back this whole time but
the second
vision's life is in danger and that
lying about like you can't
well there's a lot something about like
he's already dead you can't kill him
again yeah you can't
kill your dead husband twice yeah yeah
yeah and she like yeah
the second you poke that bear like she
wants to preserve him as being alive as
much as
possible but then once you start poking
that form of denial in her brain it's
like not
a thought no yeah like this person this
brother who she's wanted back forever to
get out of my way
or hurting him and i wonder if her
attacking him in that moment will create
some level of conflict in the next
episode between her and quicksilver
you know silver vision team-up
they both can't will they team up or
will quicksilver and her have some type
of antagon
animosity between one another it seems
like quicksilver might be a thing that
draws
drives a wedge between the two of them
like he said he was there to do
yeah you know maybe it's gonna be a very
self-fulfilling prophecy
i'm not exactly sure the commercials
have have been a little bit more
apparent with specific traumatic
memories that we know
of wanda in the in the whole history of
oh i think i get it now actually i just
talked about it out loud
he turns into a corpse the kid uses
magic
and so vision's a corpse and she used
magic
after he became a corpse and there's the
irony in the tagline of like you know
yo i ate up your magic and then you know
help me hang ten
you know it's like survivors yeah you
know it's like my magic will just fix
everything all right again there's like
little things here or there that like i
might i'll like notice in the background
and stuff but you know we'll wait just
wait for new rock stars video most
apparent one to me upon watching it
right away
it's like there's some names that popped
up around like those are probably crew
members
and then uh you know there's also the
thing with the theater room like the
incredibles and the parent trap didn't
come out in the same year i thought this
was a great episode because somehow
i thought we were going to get into
answer territory we got into more
questions territory while feeling like
while it's feeling like you're getting
married
answers in the forms of questions it's
like it's like a lost episode
your suspicions have been correct in so
far as this but also what's the nature
of this now the daymond lindelof episode
to me of
i i don't uh i feel like like i got just
got more questions
yeah yeah yeah okay so because this is
true though now what else is true i
thought this was directed wonderfully
the performances are so awesome they hop
back and forth between tones so well
evan peters is just having a blasty
blaster he's more energetic than
than ever and i think like his ex i mean
evan peters ability to hop around
even the genre splices with the show
american horror story it's like imagine
being like oh we're in the 90s world
yeah i know how to do this
like you know he's the master of tone
and the thing was he was able to do that
and like
be a heightened 90s guy the entire time
but also have like the dramatic scenes
but still
not breaking that aesthetic and that's
kind of i feel like that's kind of hard
to do
so again props no it's me evan peter
i've been saying this for years evan
peters is like the next johnny deputy
this is fun
intense honestly like that felt like an
authentic
show because when we got back to the
sitcom world in the last episode i felt
very aware of the sitcom
yeah yeah and then this here i was like
no this feels real yeah they would come
back and then i would just get back into
what yeah
over here like they really do have you
sold on like cutting between realities
is kind of just like
cutting from one room to another room
definitely you know well one division
episode six
what did you all think what's your
biggest takeaway leave your thoughts
down below
holy [ __ ] can't wait to see what we have
next
week because i am thanksgiving subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button and check out the full
length scratch watch the patreon with
all the other shows thank you to eric
last but not least
jason dolan my damn good friend it was
great meeting up with you the other
weeks ago
you know time flies here in the bubble
but jason is a is the producer and
editor for the channel
cazzy reacts never puts his name in the
description box for comments i find that
so fascinating
he never wants credit for getting it
here on the real rejects over at cash
reacts all the movies they've been
reacting to they've also been covering
wanda vision
as well reactions are well
worth it do yourself a favor go check
i'll put a link in the description box
for her channel well worth your time
he's
hustling and bustling working his ass
off and when you move out to california
this year
best bet i will see you once every two
to three months
because that's the way i am oh dude
you're gonna unfortunately each other
yeah that rape man oh look out you're
gonna know everything about each other